the woke are on high alert if you
misgender a pervert I speak of
l-a-d-a George cascone who was suspended
attorney Shaya Sana for allegedly
misgendering and dead naming a convicted
trans child molester
misgendering and dead naming our
euphemisms for calling someone their
actual gender and name
you might remember the case of Hannah
tubs
yeah me I never forget a woman with a
penis
this piece of crap
who only began identifying as female
after being arrested for assaulting a
child in a Denny's bathroom
there he should have been served at
Grand Slam breakfast involving his head
on a concrete floor
Tubbs was 17 old enough to know you
should molest kids and sentenced to two
years still at a juvenile facility
because gascoat's office declined to
transfer the case to adult Court
but prosecutor say Santa argue that tubs
should have been tried as an adult
pointing to jailhouse phone calls that
show Tubbs was claiming to be trans to
get a lighter punishment you know that
thing activists said never ever would
happen but sources say that argument
made gas go into office more
uncomfortable than Rachel Levine and a
new girdle
and that's what led to the suspension
but Santa says he was suspended for
calling out gascon and misgendering tubs
while informing them they were being
played is just the excuse for the
suspension meanwhile Tubbs has been
charged with murder in a separate case
and transferred to a men's jail
which is sort of a happy ending because
I hear child molesters do just fine
there
all right Paul uh it seems this is
idiotic I can't believe he would lose
his job over misgendering but then gas
gone has been operating on like no brain
cells making stupid decisions gascon has
fully transitioned into being a
yes all right I mean we have brag at our
end of the country him at the other end
in between you have Kim Fox you have the
other one down in St Louis the other Kim
it's a disaster and what's really going
on as you and I discussed is that this
guy Santa has spoken out in the past
against this kind of stuff that's going
on in LA and so this was his chance to
come back it may be somebody complained
maybe somebody didn't but he wants to
get rid of somebody who sees through him
and that's right that's really and you
know he understands that someplace back
in there I guess gone is taking his
orders from Rob Reiner and you know
listen gascon is probably at least
giving he's giving the people what they
want you know they couldn't get rid of
them they tried to recall him and he
couldn't do it yes so at the end of the
day who's really at fault here unless
there was a rigged election well they
got rid of these signatures they claimed
which there's like you know 100 000
signatures they question a few who's
going to go through all of it yeah and I
mean so yeah uh listen you know he's
gonna get what he deserves likely but uh
what's amazing is if you think about it
they're calling him a child molester and
a murderer and apparently the thing
that's upsetting is that they're calling
this guy a guy exactly exactly
there you go there you go uh Loftus with
your hair you'd fit into any women's
jail
well I would at least put forth the
effort yeah
exactly like we're supposed to like
completely Embrace oh I'm a woman I'm
supposed to completely Embrace that what
about my feelings yes I want to be
tricked yes I want a little bit of a
surprise
yeah but this brings I think we should
start this should be a reality show
trans criminal Island right so
it doesn't even have to have trans can
it just be criminal Island no
that's why I would like I would like
criminal Islands
I could never say no to you
yeah for all these people are like I'm a
woman I'm a woman you have a beard you
gotta call me Shirley then they go to
criminal Island God did I see what you
mean trans are the people that change in
order to get into women's prison but
they don't go there they just go to a
separate trans-criminal Island yes I
would love their dreams come true like
you knock them out on the on the flight
over and if they said they were a woman
they woke up with a boob job and yeah
excellent I can be like congrats you
maybe like Ricardo maltipan and I could
be tattoo okay I I see one problem with
that though what they get to go to an
island
that's not trash though it's not a nice
thing oh okay I went to Alcatraz
McCallum
what do you make of this
I mean is he is he trying to be like
sensitive to trans people because I
don't think that's how this comes off
yeah it doesn't to me I feel like being
a person who's born a man and then
identifies as a woman and then asks to
be called she her to reflect that
identity is not the same as being a man
who is a child molester and then asks to
be called Shia her when DNA links you to
the scene of a Murder
that's not the same thing and it it's
not obviously a coincidence that this
this person also is like oh yeah I'm a
girl now so that because you're trying
to get into the woman's prison I mean
this this person's a piece obviously
like Beyond yeah a child molester
murderer and like but we'll just don't
worry about his feelings yeah and
there's still I mean they still refer to
him as a guy in the prison records but
for some reason he all let me ask you
this Martha because you've been a new
have you ever seen a delusion this broad
delusion of this gender dysphoria
spread so quickly in everywhere I mean I
had to read this story like 14 times I
was like okay
okay he's on the phone phone or she's on
the phone with with Dad saying make sure
when you come to court you call me she
okay because you need to be in on this
whole route this is a person a human
being who's accused of beating someone
to death with a rock yeah abusing two
children to me where's Blind Justice
yeah cares what your sexual preference
is you are a Christian why do you get
more criminal end of story you deserve
to be busted for the crime that you
committed and no one cares what you want
to be called there you go all right
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else